[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
LeBron James
[Applause]
before I get started on the speech that
I have I want to acknowledge all the
lives that was lost Sunday morning ELISA
Altobelli John Altobelli Carrie
Altobelli Payton Chester Sara Chester
Christina Mauser our was a banya Gianna
Bryant and Kobe Bryant now I got
something written down no they asked me
to kind of stay on course or whatever
the case may be but later nation man I
would be selling y'all short if I read
off this year so I'm gonna go straight
from the heart
the first thing that come to mind man is
all about family and as I look around
this arena we're all grieving we're all
hurt we're all heartbroken but when we
going through things like this the best
thing you can do is lean on the
shoulders of your family and from Sunday
morning all the way to this point now I
heard about Laker nation before I got
here last year about how much of a
family it is and that is absolutely what
I've seen this whole week not only from
the players not only from the coaching
staff not only from the organization but
from everybody everybody that's here
this is really truly truly a family and
I know Colbert Gianna and Vanessa and
everybody thank you guys from the bottom
of your heart as Kobe said
[Applause]
now I know at some point we will have a
memorial for Kobe but I look at this I
look at this as a celebration tonight
this is this is a celebration of the 20
years of the blood the sweat the tears
the broken down body did getting up to
sitting down to everyday in the
countless hours the determination to be
as great as he could be tonight we
celebrate the kid that came here at 18
years of age
retired at 38 and became probably the
best daddy could be singing over the
last three years man tonight is a
celebration before we get to play love
y'all man
Kobe is a brother to me and from the
time I was in high school to watching
him afar to getting this league at 18
watching him up close all the battles
that we had throughout my career the one
thing that we always shared is that
determination to just want to win I just
want to be great an effect that I'm here
now means so much to me I want to
continue along with my teammates to
continue his legacy not only for this
year but as long as we could play the
game of basketball that we love because
that's what Kobe Bryant will long
so in the words of Kobe Bryant mama out
but in the words of us not forgotten
live on brother
[Applause]